foreign
makes me sad
what does
these young girls dress like that on the
internet
fired you muted bro oh there we go
welcome back to the three Muslims of
this podcast in the Dunya we are joined
again with brother Sunny fuzz and his
mom how you guys doing doing good how
are you guys
we're doing good we're doing good it's
uh it's been a while since we spoke uh
so how you guys been listening with you
guys
what is new really a lot of the same
stuff just been staying consistent with
making YouTube content building up
different businesses
a lot of work yo speaking speaking of
YouTube content take a look at this
alhamdulillah oh you guys actually got
here you finally got it we finally got
this guys I made a little bit of a video
in my own channel if you guys want to
check that out Link in the description
about the things I've learned in the
last couple years being on YouTube with
the two brothers over here around me and
anho because a lot of people are asking
us how to start YouTube what tips and
tricks do you have so I made a little
bit of a short video
um but I do want to give first and
foremost all Praises due to God to Allah
because without Allah none of this would
have been possible
um and sunny you know you know what it
feels bro I know you you hit 100K too
easily bro but yeah well they denied me
of my plaque unfortunately how come you
don't have have a plaque why didn't you
get a plaque what what did we get a
reason for that
um it was nonsense it was like you might
have ideas that don't agree with stuff
that you know doesn't that might violate
terms of service it was some nonsense I
was like well I don't have a strike I
haven't done anything wrong all right so
basically my fault because I just I
don't really hold back you guys are
almost at 200k right yeah I think it's
at 175. just like that brought me bro do
you remember what we were talking about
a little bit backstage before starting
up or at least
um with uh sonifaz and Elena we were
just talking about death you remember
that I think that's a little bit of a
good point and uh to begin this stream
on so you know recently I'm sure you
know many of us were just surrounded by
death and I was talking to Sony and he
was saying it's just like a normal thing
nowadays you know it's something that is
just around us you know people live and
people who pass away
um a lot of people are however
unfortunately running away from this
idea of death and I think the purpose of
this life if we have life we have to
have a death and a good question to
start this stream on that I would like
to ask you guys is what are you guys
living for
I love that question
do you want to start I gotta think
there was a time when I would have had
to think and it's
again you guys know that I have in the
past year I've always been a Christian
but in the past year I've gone deeper
into my relationship with God
and I can say now that
I am most certainly living for the
afterlife I am most certainly living
with the understanding that this is just
temporary and there is an eternal life
where with all the people I love and
with God after that comes and but I have
to earn it it's not a given
um
am I earning it
um probably falling short every single
day uh but hopefully God is as gracious
and forgiving as I've been told and you
know he'll he'll he'll let me in anyway
so in in this world though it it's still
I still have to do certain stuff to live
right I still have to be a
productive citizen
in this world and for me I I that's a
harder question What Am I Living For
because that's one that I now that I
have this new understanding of life and
what my life means and this bigger
Cosmic God relationship that's now very
personal to me it changed and now I'm
not in my head about it as much I just
keep saying to God show me what's next
like
help illuminate my path because I don't
I'm taking it away from my own What Am I
Living For and what does he want me to
live for
and you know it's
it's it's so strange to even say that
because it's it's just totally different
from how we're taught here in America
like make your dreams come true Chase
your passions do what's in your heart
and to surrender that and let it go and
be like God what do you want from me
what do you think is right help me to
you know to do your work use the talents
you gave me in the way that you intended
is a totally different Converse internal
conversation and it's still fresh with
me so it it's
I feel like a baby again in a way so
that's my I kind of long answer I like
that I like that that was very in-depth
and very refreshing Sunny how about you
mine's not as uh religious at the moment
but I'd say it's seeking truth so you
know I see a lot of lies around us from
like literally everything you know the
way you're raised
um what you're taught not not by you of
course but um no these larger societal
influences and that and those things
like I was just saying like you what's
in your head you you know your truth
right everybody's out there their own
personal truth yeah where is it getting
us yeah and I was I guess I was gonna
say like just speaking Independence like
financially and you know to where I can
just kind of do whatever I want without
having someone being able to tell me
what to do but that's not really I guess
like a purpose you know that's that's
kind of just like a step in the process
so that I can continue finding truth
um throughout my life but um I I
definitely think I really do need to get
realigned with like my overall goals
I've noticed whenever I don't have those
written down I'm a lot more lost I'm not
reading them every morning it's um it's
harder to stay focused as motivated
because you know you're not as driven
and um
you know I did that all of 2021 and 2022
and I haven't done it this year yet and
I've kind of been you know not slacking
off but I could be doing better so I
definitely gotta touch back in with that
oh what are we living for
I am living for the pleasure of Allah
and
it reminds me you know what you said
Elena in the beginning where you were
like I'm trying my best I don't you know
I could be better in this and it reminds
me of this Hadith where the Prophet
peace be upon Him mentioned that every
son of Adam is a sinner basically all of
mankind is a sinner the best of Sinners
are those that repent it just goes to
show like we're by Nature by definition
or in virtue of our creation we're going
to be sinful we're not sinless you know
there's another narration where it's
it's basically mentioned that if mankind
if all of us did not sin then God would
have destroyed us and replaced us with
another creation that does sin just so
that we can repent and understand the
value of God's mercy
hmm
very like that I like that yeah
that's so you're doing the same thing
you're just trying to live what he wants
you to live yeah yeah and be his
instrument here on Earth and just do
good with this limited time we have
because people think like even the
question I was like what are you living
for
when you think about that that question
you start thinking about you know your
life and how you mentally mapped out
like this blueprint you know and how you
have all this time in the world but it's
like how do we get this audacity that we
have all this time in the world like who
guaranteed us that we have this time our
time could be done just like that
tomorrow I know you know I don't want to
get nihilistic but it's true kind of
putting that into perspective really
shows us that we really need to live for
the now and for the present moment
because tomorrow's not guaranteed
yeah right but there's there's people
that and that's and that's a very common
in modern American society live for the
now people say that
and but they still are doing that
completely absent
of a relationship with God and so
they're doing that but they're really
not necessarily living
even close to the moral
tracks that have been laid for us
um and you know in in all of our most
celebrated uh you know religious texts
so it's it and I I lived like that for a
long time I mean I'm not judging anybody
it's not my place to judge in fact I I
just wish I had woken up from it sooner
that way of life we've all been there
but I mean yeah we've talked about that
and I appreciate that that you're not
like you're also not just a goody two
shoes coming in and being like yeah I'm
perfect and I've always been a perfect
Muslim and me me I'm being like Oh I'm a
perfect Christian oh no not even close
not even close and I appreciate that
about you guys because I think it adds
humility to our conversation
100 and we ask God to to keep us humble
Allah
yeah but um yeah for me it's it's no
different from
um you two
um with the exclusion of of Sunny I'm
just kidding
and the reason I say that is because you
had mentioned finding truth I think I
think that's actually a very beautiful
thing so
thank you I think at your point in life
like that's what else can you do you
know you don't know what's true you look
for the true thoughts you know in in my
eyes and I think inshallah the eyes of
God you know that is all you should be
doing right now you know trying to find
what God wants to do you know and um
your purpose in life and what truth is
and uh as a kind of tangent to that or
to build off of that my goal in life is
to like Fayed said please Allah to
please God and um and
the way that would be done practically
is by teaching people about God by
teaching people about what God wants
from them why are we on this Earth You
know where did we come from what are we
doing here where are we going these
age-old existential questions are
inevitably going to really pull on
somebody's strengths if they don't have
the answer to these questions in one way
or another it will you know form in the
way some kind of cognitive dissonance
and some kind of worry and some kind of
stress anxiety and unsurity of what
we're doing here and where we're going
to go the fear of death the fear of life
even some people are scared to live
nowadays the the the fear of thinking
and expressing your thoughts
um all boils down to why why am I gonna
express my thoughts why am I going to
live why am I going to fight why am I
going to strive and without God you have
no real solid objective purpose so that
is my goal in this Earth inshallah for
however long I'm here whether it's
another day or another 80 years Allahu
Adam
is to work for God and to you know bring
people to the truth that Sonny's looking
for
beautiful someone else mentioned in the
comments be a benefit to others that's
definitely something else on the list
you know with finding truth you know
comes more understanding of how you can
actually do that and the correct message
to spread so if if people are stuck in
their slave mind of how to make money
that they only need to go get a job
freeing them from that if it's religion
whatever it is being able to use my
platform for good to to help people
because I've gotten a lot of really nice
messages you know from people
um that have watched the videos and seen
me talk about business or taking any of
my programs or whatever it is and um
that stuff is more fulfilling than any
of the um
I don't know any of the the Milestones
are 100K that doesn't really I don't
know that that was exciting I don't know
how it felt for you guys but it was
exciting for like five seconds and then
it kind of Fades yeah it's funny because
we spoke about that once we hit 100K and
um
we all kind of feel the same thing which
is we don't feel any any different from
when we had 100 subs or you know ten
thousand or fifty thousand for me it's
it's felt the same all throughout so you
know it's just another number and I
think that has a lot to do with our
intention in the beginning which was if
we help one person if we guide one
person no that's enough for us so seeing
that one become you know a hundred
thousand Insha'Allah if God Wills even
more I don't think is really going to
affect us
because you know what's the point of it
all if we have ill intentions or if we
change our intentions to something that
is is ill minded you know for our own
benefit uh and selfish reasons I think
that's the the point people begin to
slip so if the numbers don't mean
anything to you anymore I think that's
actually a really good sign because if
anything it just shows you're not as
super superficial as some other people
might be
yeah I mean I just I don't know it
doesn't have as big of an effect in on
your life as people think you know when
you um when you imagine hitting 100K or
getting a bunch of money you're like my
life is going to be perfect like I'm all
set the girls are all gonna want me all
this and it's like that's just not how
it works at all and it's so it just it's
also vapid you know I I just want to say
it just hits me like as your mother how
happy it makes me that we're having
these conversations it really does I
mean at your age I was like
can someone teach me how to do a keg
stand like I was just you know I was
doing well in school but I was working
full-time going to college and and
whenever I wasn't getting my stuff done
I was partying I never did learn how to
do a keg stand and I've never done one
but the the the point is I was just a
complete idiot and I wasn't on a search
for truth about life
probably had some moments where you know
scratched a little deeper into the
surface and conversations
um but really there's just it I I didn't
have
I didn't
I had the opportunity I didn't take up
the opportunity to have these kind of
conversations with adults and people
older than me and I just think it's
really cool that you're doing that but I
always think you were born older
you know Sonny was old when he was
little thank you yeah he also got a lot
of the stupid stuff out of the way
earlier because I had a lot of freedom
when I was younger so I was in a lot of
trouble and like seventh to ninth grade
you know I'm never in a lot of trouble
like it was dumb stuff there were kids
in the neighborhood in juvie like you
weren't that guy you were just yeah
listen I wanna I wanna turn water
balloons at people and stuff I wanna I
wanna touch on the point that Elena said
about how you know I was doing this
younger I wish I found it younger or I
wasn't having these conversations
earlier and it just goes to show arami
by the way Chucky text
um it just goes to show that like all of
us here today in this life
we all we believe as Muslims that Allah
guides who he Wills when he wills and
I'm thinking back to my life about you
know the old days being young and
reckless just like you were mentioning
and if someone would have come to me and
told me what I know now I doubt I still
would have listened yeah and the reason
being is there's a time when we're ready
for hidayah for guidance and unless we
get it at that time we're not going to
take it seriously so there's no pressure
for a lot of people that feel like they
haven't found that guidance but if you
pray to God for that guidance then you
will get it because that's one of the
duas of guidance that are never going to
be rejected if you sincerely cry out to
God you could be literally like God if
you're listening if someone's out there
if someone's listening someone exists
please guide me to the right path like
there's been so many people that found
God that way
it's interesting that there's a lot of
stories like that for like multiple
religions too you know what I mean like
there's plenty of stories like that for
Christianity Islam I'm sure every other
like every single religion you pray to
God and there's like a crazy coincidence
or something yeah but it's it's pretty
interesting it's amazing God's amazing
and he'll come and and
meet you where you are if you just ask
it's really crazy so a couple things I
one thing I can say I can look back and
stop me if I ever talked about this in
our last conversation and
when I was 23 or so I was living in San
Diego after college and there was this
guy Frank from the bank that's what his
his name was Frank and he worked at the
bank and he was he liked me he had a
crush on me and I would go in the bank
you know I was waitressing and I would
put in my money and he was always so
nice and he asked me out and I said no
and he asked me out and I said No and
then I finally went out with him and he
was always trying to get me to go to
church with him he was such a nice guy
Frank from the bank but I was still in
party mode I like it it wasn't I was
like I like this guy but I can't and he
was just too boring for me right too
serious and too grown up for me at the
time and before him and after him there
were other Franks from the bank people
who were wonderful who were trying to
bring me closer to God and saw something
in me that thought I could use this or
and I ignored it kind of like what
you're saying like when you were younger
if somebody said this to you that
actually happened to me you know and I
just ignored it
but in in Christianity you know we we
look at it I am seeing it now as like
that was they say that was like Jesus
chasing me all those years and he like
kept coming by and being like Hey kid
you know want to talk and I was too busy
or too wrapped up
uh so I feel blessed that you know I
finally got the message and I finally
was like yeah I'm in
but
I don't know in Christianity and I don't
know and maybe you can tell me what this
is in Islam like what happens to young
people who died before they come to it
like you know what happens to those
Souls if there's you know if God forbid
I had died at 23
and I had just been ignoring the Franks
from the bank all those years
and I never got the message like it
stinks I was blessed with more years and
more opportunities
does Islam talk about that at all
yeah so um actually Allah says in the
Quran in chapter 17 verse 15 I'm at the
end of the verse he says never would we
punish a people until we sent them a
messenger
and what the scholars have said about
this verse is that God has a you can
call it like a tradition or kind of a
rule that he would never punish a person
unless they actually receive the message
of Truth they receive The Message of
Islam
um in in our eyes you know and if they
receive it and then after that they
belied the message then that's what
makes a person an actual disbeliever
because the disbelief in something you
have to know what you're just believing
in right otherwise you're just you're a
non-believer you just don't believe in
it um whatever it is but a disbeliever
you have to go out of your way to say
this thing I do not believe in right
um or at least in your heart
so there's actually verses or uh
narrations of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him where he mentioned that on
the day of judgment this category of
people who did not receive the message
um and or died before they could they
will be on the day of judgment still
given a type of test because it wouldn't
be fair if us in this life were tested I
get the message I have to accept it
where others they don't receive the
message so on the day of judgment God
will give those people that category
people a test where he will present to
them a garden and a pit of fire and he
will say to them I'm your lord if you
believe in me jump in the fire
and if they jump in the fire and obey
God because it's something that's it's
kind of like a parable for life you know
life living for God is kind of
uncomfortable sometimes yes you have to
strive and struggle and work and give in
charity and it's it's really
uncomfortable for for you know some
points in life so that's their test they
have to do something insanely
uncomfortable almost self-destructive
um in in our eyes but then they get to
go to heaven and if they disobey God and
jump in what they think is you know good
and comfortable and say I know better
than God then they're basically jumping
into into the fire
I love that I love that story and that
imagery
yeah my friend told me something else
um people wouldn't people would do
anything to have one more one more day
back on Earth so that they can
um accept God
yeah this is similar to in in the Quran
in the second chapter Allah says that
these people wish for like so much life
so many years and had we even given them
A Thousand Years bro they still wouldn't
have changed their ways bro isn't that
crazy yeah people it is wild how people
just go about life like mindlessly like
no self-accountability they don't like
dive into themselves look at their goals
they just kind of move along and they
don't have any plans for the day like
they just but it used to be more where
you know it used to be you know let's go
back to
Middle Ages or so where everything was
about God your whole life people's lives
the Sun from sunrise to sundown was
about pleasing God and over the over the
years even in modern American history
you know God was still up until fairly
recent decades a big part of our of our
daily lives and our society and even you
know being taught in schools
and now you can see the results that we
are a completely Godless Society people
are just not self-reflective at all it's
and now yeah now God is hate speech like
what what are we doing like we have the
world we deserve if this is what's going
on right
um
this this does remind me when I leave
the West anytime I go to like Saudi or
UAE people are still there by and large
waking up and devoting the whole day to
God and going to sleep and I think this
is something unique to like the Godless
West as Andrew Tate says
yeah it's definitely really interesting
it's crazy thinking back to my time in
public school and like the amount of
indoctrination and they were shoving
down our throats from like the police
are bad and BLM to
um how GMOs are a good thing and we need
a you know genetically modifying our
food is good for society like we
literally had a meeting about that
really yeah I'm not even joking I just
remembered this today I new stuff pops
up all the time where I'm like I cannot
believe they told us this like all the
transgender stuff non-stop I mean that's
everywhere now it it's just absolute
Madness the amount is nonsense they
shoved down our throat and if we mention
God we're Freaks and phonetics and um
trying to you know Nazis fascists like
the things that they call us for caring
about Allah or God Jesus yeah the word
of Muhammad all of it it's too much it's
I don't know what I don't know what to
do except I I
love that we're having these
conversations
there's obviously a hunger for this
because you just hit a hundred thousand
Subs you know and you're just getting
started
and there's a hunger for this and people
know that they're empty
and I do believe that you know we can
easily get discouraged and say the world
is going to hell in a hand basket but I
see it's what you focus on right and I
I'm focusing on people coming to God I'm
seeing it I'm it
you know I'm here if you told me a year
ago I was gonna be on YouTube talking to
you guys about God and trying to figure
out like the cool things about the Quran
and where we have common ground like I
would I would have never believed it I
wouldn't have bought it I would have
said yeah okay great I'm gonna win the
lottery too right this is better than
the lottery it really is
yeah so I you know I it gives me hope to
see that you know think like the church
that I belong to they just built this
enormous new Chapel because they outgrow
they've been in the same Chapel which is
very big for 22 or 23 years and they
outgrew it and so the new one is opening
in the spring and
that doesn't happen if a church is
disintegrating and the media will tell
you that religion is is falling to the
Wayside
but I don't see that in my day-to-day
life
yeah okay do you guys get pushback
though oh yeah like from your old
friends and your family who haven't come
to it yet
it's it's lonely at the top and I don't
say that narcissistically like we're
anything above anyone else because Allah
might love other people more than we
think that Allah loves ourselves so we
shouldn't fall into that mistake but
when you do try to get on
self-improvement spiritual Improvement
most people are not about that most
people are just trying to get through
the week and just consuming their
desires their nuffs in the weekends and
they don't really understand that so it
is lonely
very it can be very lonely and that's
why I think I enjoy these conversations
so much because it's it is companionship
on this road
um talking with you guys and I love that
I get to share it with sunny in this
context because I don't know that he
wants to hear me like
sitting on his bed at night talking
about Jesus every night like although I
wish you could it would be fine
so
yeah I it's
because I get pushback about
Christianity now from my Christian
family my Catholic Family I get that
like what what's all this Jesus stuff
all of a sudden what is this what are
you are you going to go my mother called
me the other day on Sunday
I called her back and uh I was like
sorry I was in church and she goes oh I
didn't think you were going because you
had company over last night you know
like and she knew that I my sister and
my cousin were sleeping over and yeah I
was up until four o'clock in the morning
talking with them but I didn't I wasn't
up drinking till 4am because I knew I
had to go to church the next day and I
wanted to be there and she was surprised
and I'm like when are you gonna get it
like this is my life now
um I get a lot of uh
weird looks when I talk about it and
then I also get weird conversations
about like what's with all the Muslim
stuff
um that's I yeah and right did I tell
you guys about that when I went home and
I was sitting I was like catching up
with a bunch of old friends
acquaintances and they're like so what's
up with the like the Islam stuff bro
like as like a like a jab and I'm like
a quarter of the population is this
religion and you don't think it's worth
like looking into like one in four
people like devote their life to this
and you're gonna just like yeah that's
crazy bro like so do you do you really
blame them though Sunny because they're
they're kind of their eyes are closed
bro they're indoctrinated by Western
media properly that's the that's the sad
thing it's like how you
you don't you can't like get too mad at
them because that's if you just listen
to what you're taught in school then
that's what you'd believe and we've sat
in that we've sat in that way of
thinking you'd be triple jabbed you'd be
going to protest like you you
it's crazy I've judged I've judged the
way I'm being judged by other Christians
for becoming more Christian I've done
you know I've I've judged Muslims uh you
know like who are more religious like
because I just don't get it like what
please you know I got it seems such a
boring life now but like you know we
could right all the things all the
judgments we receive I've sat in that
judgment and been that judge so I I get
it but I just want to be like I just
can't wait for other people to have the
light bulb go off
you know I'm excited for it to go off
for you I know it's gonna happen and
it's starting to like you're plugged in
but your search for truth will take you
to the truth and I'm excited to see that
happen too
but yeah we're getting a lot of judgment
like and you know some of it is just
light-hearted jabbing like what Sonny
got from his friends and some of it is
you know
more mean-spirated on both the Christian
and the and the
um Muslim Jabs that I get you know like
uh I'm not going to be a fanatic now a
Holy Roller
uh all those born-agains a bunch of
weirdos and then talking to
anybody when Islam comes up you know
they start bringing up you know just
media talking points
about Islam and and it's
I just do my best to politely address it
without trying to convince
yeah you know because I just say I just
say mostly like with regards to this on
stuff like hey guys I'm really just I'm
having conversations with really lovely
people who are helping me to understand
this religion and one of our main goals
is to like you know really discuss and
find the common ground and see and see
that we we can all exist peacefully
together
and they're like oh I guess that's okay
I'm like yeah it's okay to find peace
with people who you think are your enemy
in your head
you know and there are Christians who
are absolute jerks who are out there
hurting people and there are Muslims out
there who are jerks hurting people those
aren't the people we're talking to
though or talking about we're talking
about the bulk of
true you know Believers
um I don't know so it's a lot of work
yeah heavier it's heavier lifting than
just like worrying about
yeah we're going to dinner I don't know
I don't care about that stuff like at
all though if someone's gonna judge me
for like watching videos on a religion
or looking into it like you're just a
bozo like that there's nothing else to
it to me you know what I mean like
either open your mind to new stuff or
just you know I I don't care like I
don't know that's kind of how I'm how I
feel about that stuff yeah 100 I mean
when you look at these these people and
what they say and how they act there's
just a lot of hypocrisy in it because if
you look at recent events you know they
were burning the Quran in Sweden and
people
um aren't really saying anything about
it except the Muslims the Muslims are
really the only ones doing protests
other you know Libertarians uh they
really don't care about it but if
someone were to you know do that with
the rainbow flag or the um you know the
Patriot flag
yeah or you know with the um
is not real flag then um
and I hope you guys know what I I mean
when I say not real
um then you know we'd be anti-something
but when you do with the Quran it's not
islamophobic it's not bigoted it's not
Incorrect and it's not even illegal in
Sweden he the guy who did it got
permission so when you look at things
like that you find that these people
don't have anything consistent they
don't have anything that is
um that is solid that's axiomatic
they're just going based off of whatever
Society is pushing and that's something
that is Ever Changing
um and the worst part about it I'd say
is it's not even their beliefs they're
this and this is something that me and
Sonny were speaking about the last time
it came on you know these goals and
these beliefs and these ideologies are
not something that they created they
have this weird belief that this is
something that's fundamentally true and
everyone believes in it but that's not
true it's only people who live under
that uh state with the ideology that
believes in it so this whole thing about
maximizing individual freedom and
putting the freedom of an individual
person above the community
um and this whole idea that religion is
bad is something that's unique to
Western societies for the last maybe a
thousand years since you know the um in
different uh revolutions and stuff that
they had specifically in the west if you
look at the Muslim world it's it's quite
the opposite they Advance because of
religion and then you know when uh
people in Europe saw that they took the
advancements and left the religion uh
which is is very unfortunate but you
know that history really really pans out
to today and when you put that whole
picture together you get a good Glimpse
at these people so that's why personally
it never bothers me because although I
take what they say into consideration a
lot of the time I end at the conclusion
I'm sorry this person is really just
ignorant they are presupposing that
Islam is wrong they're presupposing God
doesn't exist and that religion is bad
but that's not what's more foolish than
that
I couldn't tell you I I I genuinely
couldn't tell you with if I've been
saying this if you strictly followed the
liberal woke agenda your life would be
in complete shambles complete shambles
from a little kid if you can't focus as
a third grader you're on pills if you're
older regardless if you're obese have
good habits you get on pills to to cure
your depression yeah because you know
even though you're fat you don't go to
the gym you don't do anything good in
your life you know you have chemical
depression like yeah all right that's
that's the way it is I don't even want
to go into the rest of the stuff because
if you talk about it they shut you up so
doesn't that alone speak for itself
yeah so can you tell me more about this
this Quran burning thing in in Sweden
because I haven't I haven't followed it
at all I've seen a couple things on
Twitter kind of similar to what you just
said maybe it was you on Twitter and I
didn't even realize it but like you know
uh it's okay and I I know I it about the
if you burn uh you know you burn a trans
flag
it's hate speech if you burn a Quran
it's just fine and so I know it's
happening but I really have no context
or details at all I'd love to hear hear
what you could you know be educated on
that yeah so I in terms of specifics I
don't know much all I know is that
there's a group
um led by a certain individual who is
very much against Islam in particular in
Sweden and they actually got permission
to publicly burn the Quran to make some
kind of statements
um what that statement is I'm not sure
but you know it's clearly something that
is bigoted and islamophobic
um many nations and in groups have
condemned you know Sweden and this group
for that turkey
um as a nation
and other nations other people have
literally protested in the streets uh
against this and um I personally don't
know what his reasoning is what he would
say it is but I'm assuming it's
something along the lines of you know
um Liberty we need to be free and
religion Keeps Us in change and Islam
does blah blah blah blah blah
which is just so
ironic ironically like like laughable
yeah because religion is the most
freeing thing that I have ever found
it's crazy to live by God's rules
instead of by these man-made societal
cultural rules that are ever changing
and are mostly vapid and really all for
nothing of any substance or lasting
substance and you can't take it with you
any of it so anyway that I'm sorry to
laugh but that's laughable that religion
puts you in Chains
um now I'm sure there are some religions
or parts of religions that
are misinterpreted by human beings and
do that you know I'm sure there's there
there's some reason there
so are these protests uh have they been
peaceful
yeah absolutely they're just you know in
the street chanting you know the the
shahada which is I bear witness there's
none worthy of worship except God and I
bear witness that the prophet Muhammad
is the prophet and messenger or the
servant and the prophet of God uh sorry
servant and messenger of God you know
they're just chanting that in the street
showing that you know they're not going
to step down from their faith they're
not going to step away they're not going
to cave in and that Islam is something
and Muslims are people that you know
will be here uh for longer than a lot of
these islamophobic and bigoted people in
groups you know they will you know pass
out or pass away long long before Islam
you know Withers away
huh okay so wait I just had a question
and I lost it
go ahead no go you give me oh that's all
you think of it while you think of it
let me put up some of these uh super
chats asking about you guys okay so the
first one is how old is fuzz 19 wow 19
bro Young Buck yeah oh yeah another one
where's Angel it's late where on hell is
right now in Europe so unfortunately
you're gonna make it
do Sunny fast mom uh Sunny fast and Mom
believe in objective morality
look at us you just stopped us like what
it what
what is objective morality
yeah so objective morality is just a
standard of beliefs what is good and
what is evil that is always true that's
absolutely true as Christians believe in
this because it comes from God they
believe that sins what is sinful what is
permissible comes from God Muslims
believe the same thing you know if God
says don't do this you can't do it
that's that's you know Haram in our case
and in your case it's sinful and if God
says you know you can do something or he
doesn't prohibit it then you can do it
that's what morality is so for example
you know offering somebody in
Christianity and Islam is uh forbidden
that's objectively true
um given to us from God the reason they
ask is because
a lot of these people cannot believe in
an objective morality because they have
no way to prove that it's absolutely
true you know the whole discussion of
can you prove that you know offering
someone is wrong without using God no no
they failed to do that so I think that's
just what they're asking you okay I
think I got thrown off by the word
objective um yes I would say that that's
that's
absolutely something that I believe in
and I think that's where I go back to
that our common ground
is very strong
wait isn't the thing oh okay yeah it's
it's it's it's kind of objective it's
like kind of Ten Commandments ish if you
go back to Moses with the Ten
Commandments and honor God honor your
mother you know honor your parents
um
I agree
yeah those basic those basic rules for
being a decent human being that came
from God absolutely
yeah I mean because like the thing is
too with like the Quran that I've also
looked into it's like if you just follow
the book it's like a map for your life
to be to go well you know in in so many
different aspects which is so weird even
at the time where I was saying like
don't eat pork like they didn't know
back then like the scientific effects of
eating pork and how it's bad for you
there's so many like plucking your
eyebrows is bad because that's been
recently proven to kill brain cells I've
been talking with my my Muslim friends
about it but there's so many different
like random have you not heard that one
no way that's what he said so don't take
my word for it no I'll do research but
it's like everybody's looking that up
now
someone linked some studies inshallah
because we need to see this but if I if
I see something where there's so many
Revelations where if you followed it
your life would be better and then I see
the agenda that shoved down our throat
which is if you followed it your life
would be ten times worse
what's you know what's really so bad
yeah right what's so bad about
respecting life
I like the one I'm called an extremist
so I you know just you were talking
about about offering someone
um the I I was always a
pro-choice
supporter of pro-choice legislation here
in America
um I told Sunny that I
particip I've never
by the grace of God you know never had
an abortion but had have twice taken
women to the abortion clinic and
participated in that extent being there
being the person that drove them there
waited for them got them home safely
supported them emotionally
and now
for a lot of reasons one the science is
so much more advanced we understand so
much more about what's going on inside a
woman's body from the moment she becomes
pregnant the my my deeper relationship
with God and understanding that no life
is a mistake
that we are all his children or as you
would call his creations
so
where was I going with this you know
that I I get deeper and deeper and
deeper rooted into that
um these objective moral laws and um
called an extremist
and a woman hater
and it's really it it it's so sad for me
to see young women so flip
about having abortions it's a human
right what do you mean yeah right Anne
Hathaway that actress was like yeah
abortion is a human right and I'm like
what what human like what do you talk
like how is it a human right to kill and
where do we draw that line when is it
okay to just kill somebody
there's a very specific answer in Islam
in the Sharia it's permissible for
abortion in very extreme circumstances
for example if otherwise it would have
affected the mother and she would have
passed away and there's a list of these
but the way that they're doing in the
Godless was to willy-nilly just you know
killing babies that's not something
that's that's Haram bro as Sunny always
says
like that's very yeah all caps are wrong
I'm sorry that's really serious and what
is so wrong with
being somebody you know here we are
people who respect life and want to give
everyone a chance at being alive and
living
to their potential that God gave them
like if again if that's extreme and
that's crazy then okay call me whatever
you want that's fine I can live with
that
uh and it creates that's another thing
that creates problems in my life
because there are people that I'm close
within my friends and family circles
that are where I used to be
hmm it's hard it's hard it's lonely like
you said it gets lonely and that's where
these conversations like I said really
are Comfort to me yeah 100 and once you
become a little more
um well you know well equipped and
well-versed on you know what they
believe and how to really demonstrate
why they don't actually believe anything
objectively then I really think they're
going to um stop wanting to talk to you
about it out of out of shyness you know
they don't know what they're talking
about as soon as you explain to them
that these beliefs are not objective
they're not theirs and you you break it
down in the sense that we need God to
know how to live you know and run
society and that having these laws of
you know abortion or for abortion
um is essentially just so people can be
promiscuous without consequence you know
um and that's that's a shame because
again it's just highlighting their
libertarian views that I want to be able
to do whatever I want without
consequence but news flash this is life
you know this is not a dream if you want
to you know sleep and have a a sensual
dream go for it but in real life you
know that's not how it works and and we
deal with consequences and that's why
God has given us an instruction on how
to live life but moving away from the
Libertarians and and that stuff in the
West
I want to ask you to how you guys
believe you've grown you know since we
we all four five of us including Anil
have spoken you know in your journey and
finding truth and religion and all that
stuff yo before before you guys answered
on me I was thinking of real quick going
to pray more grip yeah and then when I
come back if you want to take that
opportunity otherwise we're going to
miss that
oh okay
um so the question was how has it
changed me it's definitely opened up my
my eyes more to did you oh oh my bad
just playing around with you forgive me
it's all good it's definitely opened my
mind my eyes more to just like the
absolute degeneracy that's everywhere I
definitely say that's the um the biggest
Factor
it's just like you can see how if you
follow this your life could be so good
and it's like a book
with so many different life lessons
that'll teach you you know how to be a
good person
um stuff about business a bunch of just
a bunch of stuff you couldn't even
imagine that I've been I've been
learning and
you know if you I mean I keep repeating
myself yeah but you're right like there
were things like sunny and I will be you
know because it's our business or online
and and some something will come up and
Tick Tock talk that's really promiscuous
and we you know we look at it now and
like I'm like it makes me sad I'm like
I'm sad for that girl I'm sad for her
she's so lost and he's like oh yikes
look at this like he he has no it not
that he can't appreciate the beauty of a
woman in you know various stages of
whatever but he also looks at that as
this isn't a girl that I want to hang
out with
no because it's crazy to think though
too that there was like a time where I'm
sure everyone went through this that you
know wasn't just born religious like
they'd see girls on Tick Tock and they'd
be like yeah or they'd follow all these
model Pages where it's like half naked
girls and be like yeah bro look at this
and I'm just at this point I'm just like
that's so gross oh my God he showed me
he showed me an Instagram of this 16
year old girl the other day in
stages of undress and positions that I
was like where are parents oh my God I I
had such a I always would have looked at
it and been like all right this girl
somebody needs to somebody needs to rein
her in but I I have like a stronger
reaction to it now because I'm worried
about her now I look at her and I think
she's she's she's gonna do so much
emotional damage to herself by over
sexualizing herself at this age when
she's she's 16.
and the things that must be coming at
her that she is not mentally uh you know
able to equip yet so it's changed our um
our tolerance for regular modern society
it really has and it's changed me
personally in how frequent even alcohol
like how frequently a drink or how much
I drink I still drink you know it's all
right I'm not but I I am so much more
moderated now
you know I I'm not wake you know if I
overdo it I beat myself up beyond belief
because I wasted a day being hung over
or even a morning being hungover where
you know it used to be like that was
just part of the morning and it was a
you know I had fun last night price I'd
pay
and now I see like I'm wasting a day
that I'm supposed to be
kind of doing this bigger work
so it's really how about now how about
you talking like before you started
talking to us or outside of talking to
us do you do you have um
question like more conversations with
Christians like me who are you know how
has that changed your if at all your
perception
of this other the other team
um
I have learned a lot uh in the last few
years that that has really changed you
know how I see Christians how is the
atheists how I see Jews how I see a lot
of different groups of people and it's
it's
it's funny how obviously there are you
know based similarities as human beings
but there's such complex differences
from group to group and and why they're
so strong in identifying with you know
who they are I I mentioned this a few
times before but I went to a Catholic
school and um I was just following my
one of my friends from middle school he
was going there and I'm like well I
don't want to go to freaking you know
this ghetto school so let me go to this
school over here
and I joined him and I wasn't really
practicing until maybe grade 11 so two
three years in and then I started
debating with a lot of Christians
um at school you know on the bus during
you know on the way to a field trip to
downtown Toronto and all these different
things
um using all these you know rudimentary
arguments that people who just get into
Islam start using against Christians
then
um you know I was very zealous back then
but I I didn't really understand a huge
part of a Christian's Journey uh with
Christianity and I would say the biggest
part of that journey is emotion
um and a lot of Christians are so
emotionally attached to you know Jesus
dying for their sins and coming to you
know basically cleanse the Earth and um
and that whole the whole passion
narrative
so
um that's why I think there's a big
disconnect with you know me in the past
when I spoke to Christians and other
Muslims when they speak they're
Christians because they're trying to
really you know stick facts in their
face and down their throat and yeah
sometimes it works uh but sometimes it
does the exact opposite because
um when someone so emotionally attached
to something you know you're just trying
to shove it in their face while you
think it's wrong and prove to them that
it's wrong a lot of the time it has a
negative effect yes
um they begin you know hating you for it
unfortunately so I think that was one of
the bigger epiphanies I had you know as
opposed to like for example the Jewish
Community a lot of them are very big on
on their group you know their ethnic
group and even if someone's not really
practicing Judaism they'll be very Stern
in saying they are a Jew because it's
both in you know in ethnicity and a
religion
so um
right yeah a lot of tangents it's so
complex and you know what another thing
that's happening for me and I don't have
the time for all of it you know I just
don't like we have to do our work we
have to make a living and you know be do
be there for family and stuff but one
thing that's happening is I'm now if I
were 18 and having the these
relationship with God and all these
feelings that I'm having in the
explorations that I'm having now I would
go back to school and I would double
major in Theology and
um world history
because the overlap of the two like all
the wars that were fought you know that
Muhammad fought that the the Romans the
Jews every time they tried to rise up
against the Roman overlords and all of
these wars that were so in in you know
deeply connected to religion and in the
name of God in some cases or just
sometimes in the name of you know
whatever
Freedom they wanted or people just
taking over the world it's it's also
closely connected and I'm fascinated
with it so that's another way it's
changed me is that now I find myself
late at night on Wikipedia like just
Rabbit Hole Rabbit Hole Rabbit Hole
these obscure Biblical characters but
not just their biblical role like the
the historical role or
you know learning about Josephus who was
you know a political uh um historian in
the time of Jesus
you know who mostly wrote about politics
and history of the time and you know had
had a bunch of stuff in there about you
on the Baptist because John the Baptist
was a big Prophet at the time uh and so
I I just have these new this all these
new intellectual interests because of
these conversations also and that's
really fun
um now I wanted to say someone someone
mentioned it's pre-recorded totally this
is not a live stream I just came back in
time and put your comment up
what you got against ghetto schools uh
the ghetto part oh makes sense right
yeah but um I just I say that because
the name of the school the first part
sounds uh like ghetto
um I won't say the name for privacy
reasons so it's it's it's something that
rhymes with ghetto and then Veil so we
call it ghetto Veil for that reason
um it's just more of an inside joke for
anyone living in the area but um yeah so
back to what you're saying Elena
um I I think like this is this is
usually level two for uh religious
people because for Muslims it's a lot of
it is is spiritual and emotional as well
um when you get to the more intellectual
side of things you really have to look
at the history The credibility and the
sources and all that and um this is
something I was doing a lot of research
um with recently
especially in preparation actually for
you know talking with you guys again
on um you know the the historicity of
Christianity and Islam and all that
stuff if you guys are interested in
talking about all of that but um
who I want to ask predominantly where do
you learn from because obviously as with
Muslims there are going to be closed
circles that only teach certain things
about Islam about Christianity and about
the histories
is this something that you're exploring
at all do you want to answer or just not
does not apply right now for you
um before I answer you can answer uh so
I'm reading
um right now a lot of books written by
Christian uh theologians or Christian
Scholars and I do a lot of research on
Wikipedia
uh which I don't necessarily trust
because I I think that a lot of the
stuff on there is that I find is
sometimes slanted I find for older
historical stuff it doesn't feel
um
they just they kind of leave out like
woke type stuff so it feels maybe
there's some more credibility there
um but and then I'm also tonight I'm
starting a seminary class like a college
level Seminary class at my church and
I'm taking one semester uh just one
course for the semester and I'm a little
scared because it's heavy subject matter
and it's you know gotta like read like
seven books and write a couple papers
and do all this other extra stuff that I
haven't done in decades so that's going
to be interesting
um so definitely
my
my historical stuff
Wikipedia my religious stuff definitely
coming from in the Christian World
um and whatever thing I when I look up
stuff about Islam it is on YouTube and
also Wikipedia so uh we have there's a
copy of the Quran sitting on the kitchen
counter that um I believe you guys sent
to us thank you of course Sunny Sunny's
been Sonny's been you know dipping into
it I have not yet and not because I'm
not interested just because I just
haven't gotten to it yet but I feel like
when I finally pick up a hard book about
Islam I think I I feel like I should
start there
yeah and then I can get into and then I
and I will ultimately read a book that's
like Islam written by a Christian
scholar Islam about Islam by a Muslim
scholar because I I think that you can't
just look at one or the other you know
if you're reading about Christianity
from a Muslim perspective you're going
to learn stuff but
you're gonna learn different stuff if
you read a book that I give to you right
yeah so I'm all over all over the place
yeah either just said that no worries
it's a good thing because
um anyone who is willing just to put
themselves in an echo chamber you know
matter no matter what their beliefs are
if it's liberal or Muslim or Christian
or any other belief atheists as well if
they're going to put themselves in in an
echo chamber then they're just going to
hear the same things repeated over and
over again and if they are not critical
thinkers and they will never challenge
those beliefs or be exposed to people
who challenge those beliefs so um that's
um that's what I think a lot of
Christians aim to do with Muslims and
what Muslims aim to do with Christians
as well
um I want to present to you three kind
of statements and I'm I'm more so just
looking for what your action your
reaction would be to these statements
um if you're okay with that Elena I I
say you specifically because Sunny
doesn't seem as you know
um inclined as you are to to learn about
you know uh Christianity in the history
okay with that I'm also curious to see
what Sunny has to say though if there
are any reactions so yeah yeah bring it
let's go so the first statement
is the gospel accounts Mark Matthew Luke
and John and the New Testament as a
whole is not historically accurate or
reliable
so what I know what you know I'm a
beginner what I'm learning what I've
learned is that the reason they are the
gospels is because they were put through
rigorous comparison and
they were they would put their rigorous
comparison where all the key points line
up and actually do do make sense
together and they they support each
other also
um you know certain parts of it are very
much historically uh proven geography
there's a lot of places you know people
who are in different places at different
times
um politicians and their records line up
with a lot a lot of what happened in the
gospel
so it's it's that's a talking point that
I hear that I've read about
um uh from a Christian perspective and
it is it is entirely debunked and I
think I was supposed to come prepared to
Market this time but I I forgot because
it's been crazy we've been crazy and I'm
packing for a trip and stuff so
um I I that doesn't bother me when I
hear that anymore because there is
actually so much
a factual evidence and scrutiny that has
come from the Christian Community that
has that has validated the Gospels
okay all right and that's that's a
common narrative actually in my research
I I came across that counter argument
that rebuttal which is that there are
things in the gospels that are you know
geographically correct or politically
correct or in line with like you know
what the Jewish law was saying and all
that stuff
um and I also got a kind of more
information on that so the reason I
believe
um 100 of the Gospel accounts in the New
Testament as a whole but let's stick
with the gospels for now are not
reliable is because and I have a few
notes here
um this is New Testament scholarship
consensus so there is no new New
Testament scholar as far as I know on
the face of the Earth that really
disagrees with this
um
and that is that there are no eyewitness
testimonies that can be accredited to
the gospels at all
the authors of the gospels did not claim
to be eyewitnesses and if they were then
that would have been a big thing that's
not true some things they were like
um two so you got Matthew who was a
direct disciple of Jesus that is a
firsthand account
of almost everything that happened there
um yes there were only the women were at
the
um at the cross because the disciple the
apostles were chased
um they were all running for their lives
at the time of the crucifixion uh so but
all of the the Miracles were witnessed
by
you know a great number of people and
there are eyewitness accounts they have
been scrutinized and they were
scrutinized very close in time to when
these events happened
so you know right at the very early
church you know Saint Peter or um
Who We Now call Saint Peter Simon Peter
who was Jesus's uh apple of his eye his
favorite disciple he was the first pope
of the Catholic Church uh he was
involved you know in a lot of the
setting of the exact very specific
standards by which they were evaluated
so there are eyewitness accounts and
there are some actual artifacts that
prove that certain people were in
certain places at certain times oh God I
gotta get better at this
challenging me but like I I would
actually love for you to read the case
for Christ even if it's oh I'm not
trying to get you to you know convert
that's not gonna happen it's not much
happening it's happening and it's not my
purpose you know when talking with you
but that book is so
it it there's so much research that was
that went into it that really outlines
exactly yeah how how reliable it is okay
so so yeah my what I'm trying to say is
that the person who actually put you
know ink to paper and wrote The Gospel
according to Matthew
um did not claim authorship at all yes
it's supposed to be from Matthew's
perspective and supposed to be a gospel
according to him and there are
similarities between Mark Matthew Luke
and John but or Mark Matthew and Luke
predominantly but there is a I'd say a
very simple explanation that is kind of
consensus amongst New Testament Scholars
you know including uh Christian
theologians as well so
but okay
yeah I said near consensus I know there
are some people who do believe that um
you know a more
uh kind of trinitarian Holy Spirit
inspired
um understanding I get that but most
Christian Scholars
um actually let me go through the points
and then it'll kind of all add up just
real quick though it's the opposite it's
most Christian Scholars do believe that
he wrote it there is a fringe
um who who who has right we'll talk
about that later but it yeah I'll let
you go ahead so
the reason I say this is because of the
following
the gospels when they were actually
written they were written in another
land so not you know Palestine at the
time they were in another place like
Syria and other lands and another
language in Greek which none of the
disciples spoke and um most of them I
think didn't even know how to read or
write to begin with even in their own
language so Greek would be completely
out of the question for them and it was
40 to 65 years after Jesus's death which
gave basically people 40 to 65 years to
circulate stories whether they're true
or fabricated but the 40 Years Later by
the time Penn was put to Ink in the
First Gospel According to New Testament
scholarship Mark was written
um it had already been at least 40 years
and upwards of 65. so what was actually
put into there
uh we don't know if it directly goes
back to the disciples themselves or the
Apostles of Jesus
um um can I can I jump on that real
quick
um Luke was a doctor so he was not only
highly intelligent he was highly
literate Matthew was a tax collector who
was uh extremely
educated Highly Educated
um I don't know I don't know but I it is
not it is not outside of uh the realm of
um belief that that he might you know
these men were educated
um
I don't know about I don't know enough
about Mark to speak to him and um I know
John was literate but I'm not sure what
his uh profession was he may have
beneficial he may have been one of the
fishermen but I I can definitely speak
to Luke and and Matthew as both being
Highly Educated men so to to say that
they're they're they're not even
literate is is just inaccurate and
that's where
if this information that you're getting
is from
you know
like where is it coming from yeah are my
questions you know so there are new
testament Scholars um bar Ehrman
someone's like that is quoted a lot
um for the gospels basically this this
is statement this is a statement that
kind of summarizes it and I'm going to
provide New Testament Scholars who I
believe are actually Christian
theologians as well uh that you know
assert this claim as well so there's
zero evidence support that Jesus's
crucifixion was written by eyewitnesses
not in Christianity uh or sorry not in
Christian Jewish or Greek sources and
Dale Martin and Raymond Brown both uh
kind of concede to this point and that
is their opinion and I did mention yeah
they weren't there because they were
running for their lives because they
were being persecuted
um but they eyewitness accounts are from
the women Mary Magdalene Mary Jesus's
mother
and uh some others who were actually at
the scene so that is true so so that's
accurate but there was an eyewitness
account not a first person account in
that situation yeah but the the point
that is being made is that the gospels
were not written by eyewitnesses nor can
you attribute it to any eyewitness so
for example if there's a there is a
person who was and this is the key Point
by the way very not just literate but
trained and skilled in writing uh
stories and and so on and so forth they
actually had specific scribes who
basically that was their job and the
reason this is important is because
in in throughout Greek history
historians and other writers they
actually had a habit of inventing
dialogue
um basically wherever there was a gap if
they did not know what was said or what
conversation was held but they knew a
conversation was held or assumed must
one must have been held they had a habit
of actually inventing dialogue to that
which they believe made the most sense
so you have a Greek trained writer
writing down basically in the name of
Mark Matthew in the in this case I'll
stick to the first one the earliest one
in the name of Mark
um with no claim of being Mark and and
basically we are to assume that they
have the correct source
yeah Matthew you can tell stylistically
uh the differences so if you open up the
Book of Matthew it just starts with this
like
dreadfully long list of the uh of
genealogy you know like going way back
to I think predating David
um and how all the genealogy led to
Jesus right it's it's more technical
because he was a mathematician he was a
he was the tax collector and that was
the way he his mind worked so you can
see the stylistic differences in the
gospels and by the standard of even if
he narrated them
to discredit it is is then that standard
could be applied to the Quran because
Muhammad was also not able to read and
write so and and I and I and I don't I
don't apply that standard to the Quran
and I think that's fair to do that
because it's such an important it's such
an important work
um to you know
billion two billion people at the moment
even more throughout history so um it
it's just
yeah like these are these are arguments
that I there was this group of um
theologians that got this uh they got oh
God it was in like the 80s or so
I wish I could remember the name of them
where they got a lot of media attention
for basically saying that it was all
nonsense and most of the most of the
gospels weren't true and they were a
fringe group and they were really like
fought back on and the media but made
them seem like they were you know the
gods of this information and if you look
at the media I mean that is their job to
make themselves the gods and to make pop
you know pop culture icons and
politicians and people empower the gods
so they want to take power away from God
so that is I mean I'm not sure like this
sounds like something that came from
that group I I wish I could remember the
name of them I can't right now
but you know but feel all every
everything that I'm reading is is
validating the gospels and I loved and I
do need to share that with you and I
would say start with the case for Christ
as a an interesting place
yeah around me just a quick reminder uh
they do have to leave by 6 30 which is
in like about 15 minutes
um like a prior engagement
we could do part three yeah we're coming
back we're gonna we're gonna talk I love
talking to you guys yeah yeah inshallah
just to um to wrap up this this
conversation I do want to clarify two
things because I think that maybe
there's a bit of uh confusion on it uh
firstly when we look at like for example
the Quran uh which you brought up like
versus the gospels and even the Hadith
for that matter we have a chain of
narration of who said it leading back to
the prophet so let's say you know Imam
Allah made a a compilation of things
said by the prophet for every single
narration in that book we have bukhari
heard it from this person who heard it
from that person who heard it from that
person all the way back to the prophet
peace be upon him and all throughout the
life of the or from the the you know
passing of the Prophet peace upon him to
that time they they were actually going
and writing about these individual
people as narrators are they authentic
are they known to be a liar do they have
bad memory and the level of details is
actually astronomical and the reason I
draw that comparison compared to the
gospels is because it's a whole other
land a whole other language
um
and um a whole other
um I would say narrative even because
you mentioned that when you line up all
the gospels you find the same story uh I
believe you're you're referring to what
they call Q Source q and the best
explanation for Q is that this is
something that was closer to the time of
Jesus this Source cue that was not inter
basically no one intervened on this
narrative so Paul didn't jump in and say
what he thought and and others so it's
closest to the time of Jesus and none of
it actually contains any of the passion
narratives Q if you were to go and see
you know read through q and what the
source is there's no crucifixion for and
dying for the Salvation of humanity
there's no Resurrection there's none of
this passion narrative stuff it's more
so focused on you know Jesus's life and
things you were saying and preaching you
know that the rich are far from Heaven
and the poor closer and so on and so
forth so Paul Paul actually was an
eyewitness to
um you know all of his uh Ministry
Jesus's Ministry and Luke was um one of
his
one of his students so Luke's so Luke's
account for example is a direct
account for what he was taught and told
by Paul so Paul did have a a big hand in
the in the gospels yeah
so yeah I mean it's just it it seems
like there's just so much work to
discredit the gospels all the time but
far more work has been done and this is
actually more French information far
more work has been done to credit them
and and then I think that that's that's
the reality of why you know a third of
the world is Christian
you know because
there has been so much proof and so much
and there's also
historians of the time like I mentioned
like Josephus who validate
a lot of what was seen you know why how
did Pontius Pilate like uh end up
regretting his decisions and coming and
coming to Jesus it's also not that to me
it doesn't seem like that big of a
stretch that any of these would be
written in Greek because the first of
all one of Jesus's biggest
um requests of his disciples the the 12
was
I'm gonna I'm gonna put that
power of the Holy Spirit In You and I
ask you to Go Make Disciples of all
Nations
and baptize them in the name of the
father and of the son and of the Holy
Spirit I can't remember then exactly
where it is in which verse but that's
that's how it goes and so for them to go
and he sent them to the Far Corners of
the Earth
as far as they could get walking or you
know on a donkey right back then it
wasn't like now and sent them out it
isn't it it is not a stretch that they
would learn a new language
especially there's nothing else to do I
mean it's not like they could just hang
out on Tick Tock and waste time
so so those things like they're just I
so I I would actually heavily disagree
with with the the statement that a lot
of work has been done to credit the
Bible I would actually say the exact
opposite there have been a tremendous
amount of work done to demonstrate that
the gospels are actually not
historically reliable in that they were
um either conflated with Paul's belief
paulian Christianity or just complete
Fabrications and falsehoods and one
example uh now I know this is a common
argument that uh like I mentioned what
was his name
um Dr Peter Williams made which is that
you know oh you find geography in the
gospel is accurate you find that these
laws that you know they believe at the
time were accurate and all that stuff I
really think it falls short because you
mentioned you know pilate who was the
governor at the time and he seemed so
remorseful for Jesus and you know kind
of declared this man he was the only one
who really declared this man is the Son
of God the the Jewish mob that was
really pushing him to you know
punish Jesus and so on and so forth you
know you're no friend of Caesar and that
stuff that they were yelling at him you
know
this is not historically accurate with
what we know about Pilate from Josephus
and from Philo because
Philo described pilate as a man of
stubborn cruel and inflexible
disposition and Josephus specifically
said uh that pilate was willing to off
an entire mob or a bunch of Jewish
people just for peacefully protesting so
yeah he was a sicko he was full and his
heart was changed by Jesus and that's
and that's so that's the thing that's
exactly why it's not exactly
historically plausible so if someone
wants to make the case that well there
are geographical truths and things in
the gospels and that's what you know uh
that's what kind of authenticates them
and shows that it's it's real despite it
them being written and honestly and all
that stuff it really falls apart there
because that's not something that's
historically plausible that pilot would
all of a sudden for this one Jewish man
declare that he's the son of God and and
turn and say you know my hands are clean
from you know the sins of of this Jewish
job that's not something that's
historically plausible I I never heard
him say I never heard that he said that
um but I listen here's what I'm going to
do okay because I'm not I'm not prepared
and I love that you're prepared what I'm
going to do is take this part of the
conversation and I'm gonna do a reaction
video to it which is not fair
but I acknowledge in advance and you and
then we can maybe even watch that
together and and react to it so because
you know somebody is telling you know
somebody put up a comment prove it this
and that I I have read a lot about this
and like all these things that you're
saying to me aren't foreign but I'm just
not well versed in enough in it I'm
taking my very first theology class ever
tonight starting in you know an hour so
I'm very excited about that I don't
expect those answers tonight but I know
where to find them because I've I've
read a lot about these things so I'm
gonna do that and then I I would like to
you know respond that way
if that's okay and then we can you know
get back together and take it from there
because I I again I I know that and and
the key thing I think is also a French
um conversation but I will address that
as well this specific thing
I'm gonna address all of it
okay
to all the comments saying she always
says that she is running away no that's
listen there's no compulsion in Dean
right she has to do her own research but
she's basically saying that you know
next time it'll be a little bit more
prepared yeah it's it's not easy to come
onto a stream and you know have to
discuss things um this deep in this uh
academically complex you know I'm not
I'm not claiming that I know everything
and um you know I'm more prepared now
than I was last time but last time you
know I wouldn't have appreciated someone
you know making those kind of comments
and uh to be completely fair and honest
I don't think a lot of you guys would do
much better
um given a platform like this let's be
respectful Elena thanks guys I'm not
hurt by the comments but thank you for
standing up for me I appreciate it
yeah
you're gentlemen and I appreciate the
defense without without saying the H
word or the G word how would you guys
answer this the pope has okayed
basically the LG TV Electronics movement
uh what do you guys think about that
he has not well it's only just gay
lifestyle lesbian and gay lifestyle yeah
Pope Francis let's let's try not to say
those words because we're going to get a
we're gonna strike oh oh oh okay I see
oh I didn't oh gosh
um and people lost their minds and
there's a lot of I I am a bad Christian
in this and that I do not have even the
slightest problem with gay marriage and
a gay lifestyle uh with G lifestyle and
I I have real problems with the
um tqia Plus
um agenda that's being pushed on
children and the over sexualization
that's happening to children but the LGB
community all they ever wanted was equal
rights here on Earth and I believe that
they should have that and have that
choice and it's if they're if it really
is
uh something that God is against they
can deal with God on that God can deal
with them on that but they're not
hurting anybody
so they're really not and I don't think
they are because they never once said I
want to go into schools and make
children like me so what do you what are
your thoughts on yeah so what are your
thoughts on uh scientific literature
proving that majority of those I'm not
gonna say the word but the P you know
those that are older and they prey on
younger people majority of them are part
of LGB so meaning you might say Live and
Let Live but it literally by and large
makes the community and all the kids at
a greater risk of being taken advantage
of
so
um
I I haven't seen that data and I would
love to
but for the sake of conversation I'll
I'll I'll assume it's true
um if the P's are leaning towards that
we also know that a lot of times that
you become a p because you have been
abused in the past and so I think that
in that case I don't think that talking
about a p and talking about A really
lovely uh productive
loving couple who are same-sex is the
same thing
I I don't think that they can even be
compared and I don't think it's fair to
compare them you know like
but yeah if the peas happen to be um
same-sex attracted I think a lot of that
probably has to do with the abuse that
they enjoyed that got them there okay
and then what about what about like the
spread of like the diseases like HIV and
AIDS that it's clearly linked to that
it was most it was most prominent in
that Community yeah
um
I don't know what to say about that
except that that just sucks I mean what
do you like I don't know I don't know I
don't get it like it we can't just have
like a Live and Let Live mentality like
it does sound nice but there are
implications of that to some extent
um I think that promiscuity it doesn't
matter like excessive promiscuity
whether you're g l b straight whatever
is is unhealthy for you yes mentally and
physically well that's also I think
promiscuity is the problem
but the veggies and L's in my life who
I'm actually very close friends with are
married
um they live by pretty much all the same
values I do
and they're they're contributor
wonderful contributors to society
they're kind they're dedicated to each
other they're dedicated to their
families they live pretty traditional
marriages
so you know I don't I don't think it's
fair to lump everybody in together
because we have you know straight people
who are super promiscuous and that's the
promiscuity is the common thread
that's the problem and that's where
disease gets spread
and and you know emotional and spiritual
just emptiness
so yeah I I don't know yes my Christian
brothers and sisters who all hit me over
the head of the club and try to do
something like that and I accept that
that's fine
yeah
from for me personally I think um a big
mistake is made when there's too much
Focus or too much leniency put on any
topic or any sin like in Islam is sinful
um and Muslims and they they won't
really go back on that that is something
that is you know sinful Allah is
something that's explicit and um
although we you know are not out to
control anyone we believe that it is a
sin and an Islamic Society that's
something that is not permissible
um this was a huge talking point about
kotara and all that stuff recently
um but again it's just a matter of this
we don't have secular liberal beliefs we
practice Islam and if you don't like
that good for you that's that's just
life but um and I think that's okay I
don't have a problem with you believing
that either and that's where other
people get mad like other people who are
supporting of those the initial clubs
are get mad at me for not being mad at
you Mike come on you know everybody
needs to just like if we're all out to
believe what we want to believe
like yeah that includes Muslims leave
them alone yeah 100 yeah and I
appreciate that very much because
um you know islamically it's just a sin
like you know uh adultery outside of
marriage between a man and a woman it's
they're both sins and we we don't really
have a classification of citizenship
based on these things like in the west
they do that's that's all a person is in
the west you know
um that's who they are that's their life
that's you know the main focus and um
now they've extended it uh to literally
their identity what they identify as and
all this stuff uh they've extended it to
Children they've extended that sexual
identity being the main identity to
children and it's unbelievable and I
know the West that's our reputation but
not all of us are like that and even
even the you know and I'm not just
talking about the people that are
getting more jesusy like me I'm talking
about like regular people are looking at
it even if they don't have a
relationship with God and going oh hell
no this is not okay so try not so pray
for us but try not to think that we're
all off the rails because we're not
we're not please 100 I mean I live in I
live in the west as well so you know I'd
have to throw myself under the bus on
which uh I'm not gonna do yeah no you're
you're on team sanity I know I know what
team you're on yeah
um yeah I think we're probably I don't
know what time it is but I think we're
going to go funny do you have to leave
too or I do have to leave no I gotta go
dude I'm so hungry right now we'll do
like a little bit of a live q a after
Sonny fast and Elena leave but it was a
pleasure hosting you guys it really was
inshallah next time we can come in with
a little bit more prep work and I think
it'll be good I know I'm sorry it's been
crazy we've had like we started we've
had a lot of uh loss and a lot of
unexpected travel and uh I
I didn't come as prepared as I'd like I
I'm gonna come as prepared as Rami one
time and y'all gonna be blown away okay
yeah I love it I love it I love I love
this conversation I can't say enough how
grateful I am thank you guys
of course of course it's our pleasure
inshallah hopefully we can uh all get
together soon with Angel as well and
continue the discussion yes we tell them
we missed them today we will we will
absolutely and uh I'm sure the feeling
is mutual and butterflies and for
everyone who joined uh if I had Sunny do
you guys have any uh final words I think
me and Elena spoke for the majority of
the second half no bro I think I think
me and you Rami will just stay for a few
minutes just quickly wrap the Q a but
nothing Sunny what about you I don't
have too much more to add I saw a lot of
spam for Hamza so I guess we'll have to
get a Hamza I guess I have to get um a
collab with him going but um yeah thank
you guys so much for watching I'm glad
that you like to hear us talk and we'll
do it again inshallah
um by the way hums is the the brother
that I sent you on Instagram DM so if
you want to find his page and check the
DM between you and me and uh you should
find the link there beautiful
all right thank you guys so much for
joining uh this has been an amazing
conversation and we look forward to
speaking you guys again soon all right
talk soon guys take care
all right so
first uh firstly first order of business
first of all shout out to you alone
about it probably supporting the channel
but he writes I don't know why I don't
get notifications from this channel
anyone else have this problem guys
please let us know this is like
unacceptable YouTube come on
okay someone asked this
even though it's for Sony around me do
you want to address it uh Sunny how do
you see the relation between the
definition of God being Eternal slash
undying in Jesus upon him dying on the
cross please read the Quran well yeah
that's definitely for sunny because I
don't uh I don't have a problem with
that because I don't believe Jesus Is
God and I don't believe he died either
to be honest not yet
look at this someone no I don't get
notifications out on any yeah I have the
same issues
I think this means I don't either
what's the problem bro yeah we need to
um tweet actually no we we can we have a
direct contact now because our channel
is uh monetized but before my channel
was monetized bro I had to tweet at them
so it's got to make some noise inshallah
and get them to fix it YouTube something
else yeah
uh slam Brothers I have a question is it
true that I find uh in holidays I don't
need too fast but if I come back I need
to fast for missing the Ramadan days
thank you um if you are traveling yeah
you don't have to fast if you're a
traveler
um and you do have to make it up
afterwards but holidays doesn't just
mean you go down the street
um you know to uh an Airbnb and chill
for a week that's that doesn't happen
next question someone assistant Maria
asked my friend asked why men can have
multiple wives of polygyny but not
polyandry which is one woman with
multiple men so the easiest answer would
be understand that in Islam Islam was
here to basically eradicate a lot of
different issues from the ummah and just
from the world even non-muslims one of
the biggest issues is Assurance of
paternity we look at studies today where
kids that don't know who their father is
how that's problematic the implications
of that not just with lineage but
inheritance mental health there's
immense issues
now one of the biggest issues is
accountability how are you going to know
who you're accountable if you don't know
who your kids are so in Islam polygyny
up to four wives is permissible because
if a man has multiple wives everyone
knows who the mother is and everyone
knows who the father is let's say the
man impregnates all four of their wives
right all all of the kids have that man
as the father and their respect their
mothers because it came out of the woman
do you know what I mean now imagine one
woman has multiple and it's not gonna
work No One's Gonna know who the father
is I know today we have paternity tests
but the way it's done logically it
literally makes no sense like you will
not be able to tell this is number one
number two without me do you want to go
um I just want to say that um listen God
and this is not an argument people like
to accept but if you think about it
logically uh it is the strongest
argument God is all-knowing and all wise
he created human beings he knows what is
best for us he knows what is moral and
immoral so if he says men can have
multiple partners with the conditions
that he marries them
only up to four he takes care of them
and he treats them all equally then that
is something that's permissible and the
same is not allowed for when again
because God knows that that is not
something that is beneficial for men and
he did not create women to be uh
polygamist in any way that I think is
the best answer because yeah you go to
the something axiomatic you know Allah
is all-knowing and he's all wise he said
so that makes it objective if you want
to look for more like the wisdom behind
it in this life then what Fayed said
definitely stands up um you could just
look at you know men psychologically are
able to love multiple women in a way
that a lot of women just are not able to
love multiple men and they are will not
be able to be equal with those guys and
if you think about it let's say she gets
married to four people and she's
pregnant you know is she really going to
Tire herself out uh you know sexually
accompanying every single man while
she's pregnant oh you know what if what
if she only wants two children then if
one guy is super lucky he'll have two
kids and if two guys are reasonably
lucky then they'll have one each and the
other guys will have nothing now those
things like sperm competition and you
can look at all these arguments but I
think it's useless I think the first one
is just the the simplest and most
straightforward we are Muslims we obey
Allah and that's uh what it boils down
to alhamdulillah guys just a quick
disclaimer we have about 10 to 20
minutes max so most likely it'll
probably be around 10. I don't know when
Romney has to go but please ask your
most important question super chats are
guaranteed because they show up above
all else
um and we definitely do want to answer
these before we wrap it up
yeah depending on what I can probably
stay behind
um inshallah and we're going live on
Saturday uh 12 p.m Eastern Standard Time
anyway in case we don't get everything
done today
remember you want to pin some comments
up bro
sure let me see
I have this one if you want to answer it
okay I was just about to put one up but
uh slime Brothers I have a question is
true that I already answered that nope
yeah
um
I think we're both trying to put
comments up yeah this is the last one
live uh I shot all the time to see when
you guys are on good luck today
bro something's happening with YouTube
I mean but um
yeah so there's one I think I lost it
here how many wives are you allowed to
have
um four is the max for a man if he's
able to be you know fair with all them
and take care of all of them if he can't
be equal then he can't have multiple
wives and if you can't give them all the
kind of the same standard of living then
he's not allowed to marry more than one
wife
isn't the tough series the default is
polygyny like you have to marry two
three and four if you can't you fear you
can't be completely just or at least
near that then you marry one
um yeah there is that opinion that um uh
since Allah starts with saying Mary two
three and four he's encouraging polygeny
yeah
um but uh you know
I don't know there are difference of
opinion on that I I think you know I
think that's a reasonable opinion yeah
100 but you know it teaches our own
depends on the context there is a time
where
um I think the the Emir at the time made
it obligatory for everyone to have at
least two wives because there was just a
lot of unmarried women you know
obviously that's uh a fitness for them
[Laughter]
uh didn't we do a stream with Bobby's
perspective yeah we already did this
like a year ago and shella will bring
them back yeah inshallah
um is it permissible to persuade your
husband not to marry a second wife um
it's it's it's permissible to tell them
that you don't want it and to try and
you know
um get him to not marry another wife but
if he wants to and he's able to you know
that is his right
um but I always recommend speaking with
whoever you want to marry about this
beforehand
um and settling it before you guys get
married because you don't want to put
yourself in a situation where it's for
some reason the worst thing in the world
for you but he gets another wife and
then you go through all this like
emotional trauma and stress because
you've been taught your whole life that
it's wrong and you have to deal with
this cognitive dissonance so you can you
can try but at the end of the day just
know that Allah has made it permissible
for him and what would be better is that
you understand that it's not something
that's bad it's not something that's
wrong and that's going to take a lot of
work from you and a lot of work from the
sisters but um if they have difficulty
without they start with what's more
basic who is Allah why do we worship and
while he's worthy of worship and and
start with the basics of you know our
belief in Islam
um okay
someone wrote Matrix is attacking you
guys that's why no notification
let's see
is the Discord up if so what is the link
yeah it is uh did we put it in the
description yes
in the description you guys can join up
and show Allah forgot to announce that
so for asking
um
a member pardon me and inshallah many
many more to come
if the wife doesn't agree then you treat
her less right then he isn't treating
them equal
um no not at all treat in terms of um
you know how much you give to them we're
not able to equally love or feel the
same exact emotions for people we're not
judged for that it's based on you know I
don't get one wife a 2004 Toyota cam uh
Toyota Corolla and I I buy the other one
a C-Class Mercedes uh that's brand new
you know that would be unjust unfair
it's not that I have one living in a
basement the other one's living in a
mansion no you have to be equal with
them in that sense
hmm
uh I don't know I I don't know Costco
scholar
I do want to address something though I
do want to address something because oh
bro come on this can't be by chance and
also bro announce it yeah inshallah we
actually we're gonna have him come on in
early February I think it's the 10th but
uh that's uh I have to check so yeah
it's Friday for every time we booked it
in advance
you guys look forward to that I
definitely am a lot of the notes that I
took but I had like seven pages worth of
notes bro
um look at all this stuff man I was
ready to go uh most of it or all of it
came from uh his lectures and his uh
live streams predominantly with blogging
theology so I suggest you guys check
that out but there is something I want
to I want to discuss because I think
it's it's important
um it's kind of like the elephant in the
room the whole thing about you know
bring this person bring that person this
is something yeah this is something that
we've talked about before
um you guys as viewers you have to
understand that we're dealing with human
beings here and I know maybe it doesn't
look like it doesn't seem like it but me
personally I've been discussing with
people about religion and Interfaith
discussions all this stuff for fair few
years now and although I'm not I'm
definitely nowhere near the top of the
uh the chain in that I do have a good
amount of experience in that so yes I
did my preparation hamdad and I was
ready but I was also ready not to
discuss that stuff at all because like I
mentioned and I hope you guys got the
hint I was just trying to say that
um a lot of the time is emotional for
people and they're not ready for like
logical arguments or evidence and that
stuff and I genuinely believe that is
the case uh for for a sister Elena I
don't think she's at that place yet and
there's nothing I or Hamza or sheikhoth
hijab or anyone can do to to force them
there obviously
um
obviously these guys have a lot more
experience than us but there are some
comments I saw that were really
upsetting something along the lines of
if if this person comes and they'll
accept this time in two minutes
um that's not how it works uh you know
hidea comes from Allah and maybe Hamza
would just hit all the right points but
maybe it would be something that's you
know really tremendously bad this is
something that we spoke about after
bringing sheikhothman for the
conversation with going on
um it was it had a really negative
impact if you think about it and looking
back there could have we could have
dealt with it in a a much more wise
manner so I know you guys want to see
and I was there as well and I know you
guys want to see the review this review
that stick it in their facial evidence
make them you know cry for their mommy
that stuff doesn't work a lot of the
time it doesn't so we have to play the
long game we have to be you know fair
and genuine kind with them and I
guarantee
I'm I'm not not guarantee I'm 90 sure if
I did that to the degree you guys wanted
me to and if I stuck all these notes in
there in in their face and I I said
Elena stop cutting me off I'm gonna fish
my point and I was really rough uh kinda
like comes a style may Allah bless them
then I I don't think she would come back
again I'm gonna be completely honest
yeah and there's there's a time and
place for hamza's then type dawa and a
lot of people can't handle the my
particular personal experience with
Christians because their entire theology
their entire belief makes no sense
logically it literally rationally makes
no sense this whole trinitarianism and
when you come into it with logic they
don't they don't want to accept it bro
look at Don a man a man that you know
acts confident acts sure and certain and
secure in his beliefs look at how he
acted bro and may like item I mean but
it also show like if their entire
existence in their theology makes no
sense logically you're not gonna do much
coming at it aggressively with logic
alone
yeah yeah 100 and um I I don't think
they would have appreciated us just
bringing someone on the Fly you know
like think about it from from from their
perspective imagine you guys were
invited on a podcast to talk about your
belief um someone who's a layman in
Islam or whatever and then you know
you're invited to speak about Islam and
they bring on like you know uh William
Lane Craig or like Ruslan or someone
who's been doing it for years and they
just completely stump you with arguments
I don't think you would appreciate that
either uh and no one comes up may Allah
bless them he's he's really the type you
know that's why they call him a lion
that's why his intro is a freaking a
lion on fire because that's his style
that's how he is so I just we made a
judgment call it would not have been
fair and um I did reach out to them
beforehand which you guys don't know
um uh basically trying to get them in
touch with thumbs up so they can go and
speak them on their own volition
um so may Allah bless you guys
that's like the full story alhamdulillah
uh you guys doing a great job his mom's
problem his mom uh probably not every
fact anyway
you know we also don't want to jump to
that uh that conclusion as well
um smack that like button oh why was
everyone saying invite speed I don't get
it was that just a joke bro they were
just joking they were like invite
speeding but Mufti menk wants to join
Zucker Nike wants to join yeah right
yeah guys by the way I'm in California
um I want to speak with Aiden Ross so
everyone go to wherever his videos
stream is I think he's banned but uh
spam you know go talk to three Muslims
you know let's get him on the stream
inshallah bro pull up on pull up to his
crib inshallah
I have no idea but he invited H3
recently and I'm like bro if he's gonna
talk to Ethan Klein bro then you know
Charlotte he might as well talk to a
Muslim bro
we'll see just go comment and um
respectfully uh invite him to to come
speak with us inshallah all right so
coming up guys a lot of people are
wondering when we are going live next
Insha'Allah on next
stream is going to be this Saturday in
Charlotte 12 p.m Eastern Standard Time
uh and then after that next Wednesday
any last minute questions please let us
know right now before we wrap it up
inshallah
one person got the notification
alhamdulillah
when will Gabriel be back that's a good
question
that's a good question
I guess whenever we invite him
done Hamza says guys I'm doing a live
stream on my own YouTube channel sucks
for just wrapping it up I know I think
it's a good thing because once we end
inshallah the viewers can go jump on it
oh guys please go over the hamster's Den
inshallah show him some love in Hamza
please let's get a let's get a stream
inshallah sometime inshallah or an
organized one we don't really like to do
like last minute things
um because of the aforementioned reasons
alhamdulillah yeah
remember you want to put some last
minute questions
uh yeah sure let's uh
how many thumbs up do you guys see I
don't see any um but it should we have
1258 there should be at least 50 000
likes inshallah
we got 951
this is a good question uh are you guys
gonna open a rumble channel uh would be
nice to hear the dark truths of the
world from your perspective we have
spoken about that I think that would be
the easiest way to post unfiltered
content but we are also we have a team
working on a website for us where we
effectively wanted to do the same thing
which is post our own content on there
inshallah
Aiden Ross is on Ben by the way oh yeah
according to someone in the live chat
okay that's amazing so uh they're
testing me
yeah everyone go and uh basically
comment I don't I don't want you guys to
pay for super chat but at least comment
uh saying that you should check out the
three Muslims and uh uh that I'm in
California and I'll uh pull up anytime
inshallah respectfully
um the three Muslims uh why the apostles
oppose the ideology of Paul and what was
his ideology so if so then if Paul
considered Isa Ali said I must Lord so
is Paul in Hell or the apostles so
firstly what we have to understand is
that a lot of um Greco-Roman literature
in general I'm gonna remove the comment
but a lot of Greco-Roman literature in
general is horribly kept the time of
Jesus was more so you know better kept
because of the predominant figure that
he is or was taken to be at maybe a
later point after his uh death or
disappearance from our eyes
um but it's it's generally horribly kept
so I do want to make the the
points if you guys will permit it and
fight if you're okay with it that I
wanted to make to uh Sunny fowls and his
mom just so you guys get a good idea of
where Christendom kind of stands
academically speaking or at least from
one plausible uh historical reading um
before I do I would suggest watching the
recent video with blogging Theology and
um Dr Ali atai on blog theology channel
on the crucifixion of Jesus uh peace and
blessed be upon them and if it's
historically plausible to say that Jesus
was not crucified uh so fight would you
let me uh go through these or do you
have to go no please go through them and
uh I just want to give you a quick
warning from Brother Bilal that you're
in Godless Allegro land of shaitan
you already know that bro yeah inshallah
I'll bring them to Islam bro let me
preaching from the from the hills on the
mountains all right by the way how long
will this take approximately
um as long or as short as you need it to
be bro
oh in that case I'm here for like until
seven which is eight minutes but you can
also feel free to just continue the
stream if you want okay
um you can you can if I go on too long
which I probably will because I have a
tendency to do that you can jump in and
let me know then um I'll just carry on
into myself
so first and foremost the point that I
was trying to mention before is that the
gospel accounts and New Testament are
reliable as a whole and this is
something that is basically
um or what I'm about to say is consensus
amongst New Testaments College which is
there is no credible eyewitness
testimony from the four gospels when I
say the four gospels I mean the four
Greek writers who put down
uh you know ink to paper and wrote The
Gospel According to Mark Matthew Luke
and John
so you have basically this Greek man who
was taught how to write with his
preconceived beliefs and all that stuff
um write down the gospel of Mark 40 to
65 years after Jesus had you know passed
away or disappeared or whatever that's
40 to 65 years of you know
um misquoting
um Miss delivering misspeaking
mistranslating uh or fabricating stories
in the life of Jesus peace and blessings
be upon him there are no eyewitness
accounts of the crucifixion there are no
eyewitness accounts of the crucifixion
I'll say one time there are no zero
eyewitness testimony accounts of the
crucifixion although the gospels all
kind of appeal to those and although
there were some people who believed
Jesus was crucified this was not the
only view this was just the view that
became most dominant uh and I will speak
more about that insha Allah secondly
Paul
had his gospel circulating long before
Mark wrote his gospel
and let me tell you what what Paul
believes
Paul as some describe him was a hella uh
I think was Hellenistic
um uh kind of trinitarian a
subordinationist as well
right and this is written throughout his
works and once you dig into it and you
watch the election from Dr aliatai you
will see how in depth it really is
so Paul was a person the first person by
the way who believed the crucified
Messiah there are people who believe
Jesus was crucified but not the Messiah
and there are people who believe that
Jesus was the Messiah but was not
crucified Paul was the first person to
come take these two beliefs and mesh
them together
and say no he was the Messiah who came
and died for the sins of of humanity and
those who believe in him
so
on top of that there's a few points that
Paul writes about himself I'm gonna
there's a lot I'm gonna Zoom through
inshallah just hit the major points yeah
we all know Jesus never met um or sorry
Paul never met Jesus
um did not see the crucifixion all that
stuff but what does Paul write Paul
wrote
that his message was not given to him by
man but was directly revealed to him
from Jesus himself what does this mean
this means that Paul did not get his
information from the disciples Paul did
not get his information from the
apostles
he got his information directly from
Jesus himself so if you go back in the
chain of where Paul got it from it's
from himself he just basically said that
he heard it from Jesus uh in this Vision
that he got
Paul seemed to be the first person uh or
that I already mentioned that believed
the crucified Messiah and all that and I
want to read a few verses that Paul
himself wrote
he said in Galatians 3 1 who has
Bewitched you that you should not obey
the truth before your eyes Jesus was
portrayed as crucified now what does
this tell us
someone might glance at it and say so
what he's just preaching his belief but
if you think about it he's he's writing
to people he's speaking to people and
he's saying why don't you believe Jesus
was crucified
which shows what that people did not
believe Jesus was crucified
what else
he says in First Corinthians 2 2 I
taught you nothing except Jesus Christ
and him crucified why does he keep
emphasizing to these people that he's
teaching that Jesus was crucified
because they did not believe that he was
and when I say they I'm talking about
the James and you know the followers of
James who was the head of the temple
after Jesus peace be upon him uh had
left uh Philippians 3 19 for many people
are enemies of the cross
he's specifically saying there are many
people who he has to deal with that are
enemies to the cross
they don't believe Jesus crucified and
they're going to basically keep saying
Jesus was not crucified because he was
the only one who believed the Messiah
Jesus Christ was crucified
and I'm going to skip one and just go to
a really big one which is Romans 3 7 is
something that I think a lot of Muslims
are familiar with
where Paul writes if my lie
brings forth the truth of God how can
you call me a sinner
excuse me he's saying well I believe to
be true if I lie about it but it brings
people to the the truth then how am I a
sinner
so what was this lie that he was caught
in was it that you know Jesus was
crucified was it that Jesus died for the
sin of humanity was it that he did not
actually get Revelation from Jesus what
was the LIE we don't know but it's clear
that James had to deal with a lot of
people namely the people from Nazareth
the followers of James the ebonites who
did not believe this weird christology
that Paul seemed to have believed
and then lastly and I think the most
astonishing of all
is that Greek Pagan thought was inserted
into the Gospels
now what do I mean by this this is
something we hear a lot but let me give
you guys something a little more
definitive inshallah
there was something called
um
hennotheistic polytheism which is what
you know the Greeks kind of practiced
Once Upon a Time
um and that is the the belief
hennotheistic polytheism is a belief
basically or the devotion the acceptance
of one main god you know who fails one
main god
but also while accepting the existence
of other deities
Hinduism
is a hennotheistic polytheistic religion
Zoroastrianism is also a halotheistic
policy a polytheistic religion
Christianity is also a uh hanotheistic
polytheistic religion try to say that
seven times and you'll stutter as much
as I did but um and why is that it's
because John Mark Matthew Luke and Paul
himself were subordinationists I'm going
to close my book now alhamdulillah they
were subordinationists which means one
it means that they believe that whole
fails God himself the father is the god
but that he manifests himself or that
he'd be be basically begets or that he
not created
or created in not the traditional sense
the son the logos who was also God the
word of God right that's why you find in
John 1 1 uh speaking about in the
beginning was God and and so on and so
forth when speaking about what people
say is God he says hope fails basically
the god when speaking about Jesus in the
word it says logos you know it's a
lowercase G God which means maybe Godly
but not the God you know as the Hindus
would say Brahman or as in Greek they
would say whole face the God and what's
funny is that
Paul himself and this is the biggest I
think testimony of himself that he's a
subordinationist and not a Nicene
trinitarian is that he wrote and I can
find the source if you want I have in my
book about I close that I want to open
it anymore and bore you guys with that
he wrote the head of man is Christ and
he used the Greek word cathale which
means literally I had he said the head
of man is Christ and in that same verse
at the end he says and the head of
Christ is God
so the same way that Christ is an
authority and you know the head of us
the God the father is an authority in
the head of Christ so he was clearly a
subordinationist and this is what he was
trying to teach
that Jesus was Godly
in some sense where he's not identical
and being to God and that God sent his
half basically man God to come and die
for the sins of humanity and I'm gonna
end it there based basically just on my
own uh my own ignorance I'm not able to
delve much deeper because that was all I
could kind of study but for an actual
academic proper in-depth
um video on this again Dr Alia Tai on
blog and theology in his recent video
about the crucifixion Barack everyone
for listening to that and clarified for
staying past seven
of course bro of course I really much
look forward to it else bro if I'd be
chilling for real I mean
uh
see
Mela make me as you see me oh Mommy I
mean
all right with this being said guys stay
tuned we got some live reactions coming
soon inshallah live I mean lit not live
live recording
we got the hijabi the Shameless hijabi
bro from Tick Tock going around saying
all this
all this type of nonsense
we got another uh reaction video coming
up about Andrew Tate and insha Allah
very special things coming up for the
next few weeks inshallah we'll keep it
at that whereas on hell I miss him Angel
is currently fast asleep so I'll make
some dog keep us in your doors guys we
need you to us and uh inshallah with
this being said on me let's wrap it up
Allah
foreign and by the way how